[Music]
hi michelle
how's it going so excited we're gonna
get you dressed so it'll be super fun
and um you're going to the park
yeah yes we've got some beautiful colors
let me know yeah
and then you said you liked green i do
like green it's my favorite this is
really beautiful and
hi hi see this color is beautiful on you
ah i think this one feels a lot better
how do you feel
i'm not gonna lie i like it better than
i thought i would
i don't know but feel it that is
beautiful this color is so gorgeous
i love it
that is exciting it is
[Music]
gorgeous thank you so much
hi michelle hi you look beautiful
do i feel beautiful i want to make sure
that you're really feeling confident
about your flirting skills
and your communication style because a
lot of times if you've been in a
relationship for a long time
and you haven't been dating those skills
kind of
they wane right you need to practice
them got it
when you're on the date i want you to
think of
every time he says something think in
your mind
yes and yes meaning
you hear him you acknowledge what he's
saying
and you add on with something
from your personal experience um
the other thing that is very bonding for
two people on a date
is is mirroring you can actually
create the feeling of connection
seeing what he's doing with his body
language or his tone of voice
and mirroring that yourself so remember
those tips
i think it's gonna go great i'm really
excited for you
oh damona i love you and michelle i am
so excited when we come back we're gonna
find out what happened on michelle's
date because our cameras
followed along plus yep that's welcome
to my world and uh
she's here to give us all the details
[Music]
you